Now, the 2016 Summer Olympics
are in full swing,
which means sports fans
have lots to celebrate
and argue about online.
So here to fill us in
on who deserves gold and groans
this week
is Nightly Show Contributor
Franchesca Ramsey
with another installment
of Hash It Out.
-♪ ♪
-(bird tweets)
Thanks, Larry.
This year's U.S. women's
gymnastics team
made us all proud by taking home
the gold for team all-around.
(cheering and applause)
But before we could even start
celebrating this epic win,
Twitter had a meltdown
because Gabby Douglas
didn't put her hand
over her heart
during the national anthem.
Take a look
at some of these tweets.
"If Gabby Douglas
is not patriotic enough
"to honor her country then she
needs to find another sponsor
and go home with them."
Not patriotic enough?
Homegirl literally did
backflips wearing
our nation's flag
covered in rhinestones.
And I don't care
what you say, sir,
there is nothing more patriotic
than a choreographed tribute
to the Bedazzler.
"How dare Gabby Douglas
not put her hand on her heart
"for the American
national anthem!
#KickGabbyOutOfTheOlympics."
(groaning, laughter)
Kick her out of the Olympics?
Ugh, there's no way
this guy could get any worse.
Or so I thought until I saw
his Twitter profile.
(groaning, laughter)
But I guess I'm not surprised
that a Trump supporter wants
to deport a brown person doing
work he's not qualified to do.
(cheering and applause)
Look, she's
completely showing respect
by standing there proudly
during the national anthem.
How 'bout you show some respect
for somebody
who made it possible
for the national anthem to be
playing in the first place?
(cheering and applause)
And maybe, maybe Gabby's arms
were tired.
Do you know
how much energy you expend
doing (bleep) Olympic-level
gymnastics?
Hell, this is me after walking
up four flights of stairs.
(applause)
But the national anthem backlash
wasn't even the worst of it.
Twitter took the gold medal
in petty
when people started dragging
Gabby for her hair.
"I just want a black girl to do
Gabby Douglas' hair, bro.
That's it." Guess what, bro,
a black girl did Gabby's hair,
Gabby.
"How does Gabby Douglas' mother
even let her be
on national television with
those edges looking like that?"
"Gabby Douglas got money
and them edges horrible!"
No, what's horrible
is them grammar you got.
(cheering and applause)
Okay.
Let me just explain edges.
"Edges" is another word
for "hairline."
And when it comes to black women
and hair, edges are a big deal.
Do you have them?
Did Beyonchés...
Beyoncé snatch them
with her fierceness?
It's pretty serious stuff.
So why are people criticizing
Gabby's edges?
Well, according to Twitter,
they don't look nice enough
for the Olympics.
Gabby's competing in
the Olympics, not a hair show.
You try doing
the uneven bars routine
with a helicopter on your head.
(laughter, applause)
It's nearly impossible.
If Gabby...
If Gabby was worried
about keeping her edges laid,
she wouldn't be at the Olympics.
She'd be on the couch
talking (bleep) with you.
(laughter)
(cheers and applause)
You at home,
she at the Olympics.
Plus, your hairline's bound
to get a little fuzzy
when you're breaking a sweat
and breaking world records.
WILMORE:
All right.
Franchesca Ramsey, everybody.
-We'll be right back.
-(cheers and applause)